bonjour à tous donc je m'appelle céline
et aujourd'hui je vais vous proposer une
petite séquence pour soulager votre dos
on va à la fois étiré et bougez votre
dos dans différentes directions pour
soulager un peu toutes les tensions
qu'on peut avoir dans les épaules pour
vous permettre de mieux respirer en ces
temps où le froid et la situation
ambiante ne sont pas les plus favorables
c'est parti pour cette petite séquence
qu'on commence les pieds largeur de
votre bassin vous vérifiez bien les
pieds largeur du bassin légende
légèrement fléchi vous inspirer et on
souffle en vous resserrez le bas du
ventre vous a inspiré
en soufflant vous resserrez tout autour
de la taille pour être ce que le ventre
soit bien serrés puis vous inspirer en
levant les bras vers le ciel les jambes
reste fléchi croiser les doigts et on
inspirant vous étirer tout votre corps
vers le ciel vous a inspiré en soufflant
vous serrez levante et vous incliner sur
le côté on est tous tout le flanc droit
et vous revenez au centre fléchissez
légèrement les genoux inspiré et en
soufflant incliné vous de l'autre côté
on étire maintenant le flanc gauche
revenez au sens où a lâché enroulée vous
pour vers l'a inspiré et on souffle en
relâcher votre tête vous relâcher les
épaules vous relâcher bien la tête vous
a inspiré
en soufflant vous descendez un peu plus
bas quand elle achète toujours et encore
la tête serrer les boulons pour protéger
le dos et descendez jusqu'en bas vous
trouvez votre 4 pas vous vérifiez que
vos poignets sont sous les épaules de
chaque côté vous vérifiez que vos genoux
sont souvent vous inspirer et on souffle
insérer le ventre puis inspirez relevé
le regard resserrer les omoplates
cambrai le dos expirez arrondissez le
nous regarder votre nombre en inspirant
relevé le regard c'est la posture de
l'apache qui allonge l'avant de votre
corps expirez c'est la posture du chat
qui a on dit l'autre côté de votre corps
vous inspirez-vous redresse
le regarde resserrer les omoplates vous
expirez vous arrondissez le dos et le
petit chaperon temps vous reste il a
retourné wazers tél
vu décoller vos genoux pousse les frais
vers l'arrière il vous ramenez vos pieds
un peu vert vous retrouvez la veille
lourdes
rush in gens sont pliés absolument
les yeux ouverts vous avez terminé votre
dos une vertèbre matteo si c'est
nécessaire d'aider les mains sur les
cuisses
nous devrons l'époque d'où une vertèbre
après l'autre qu'on vous redresser la
tête en dernier déroulée bien tout votre
colonne vertébrale retrouver le ventre
serré et on reprend comme au début de la
séquence inspire et y répondra
grandissez vous croisez les doigts
étirez vous vers le ciel inspirez
expirez peut-être comptez vous aller
plus loin qu'au début de la séquence et
revenaient une fois encore de l'autre
côté incliné vous de ce côté-là et
revenez serré levante relâché vos bras
roulé les épaules vers l'arrière voilà
normalement vous avez pu ouvrir la
poitrine sentir votre dos plus grands
j'espère que ça vous aura fait du bien à
très bientôt
au revoir